Harry Styles is mourning the death of a  stepfather  Robin twist he was 57 years old and was  battling cancer 23 year olds rep  released this statement to ET on  Thursday quote Harry stepfather Robin  twist sadly passed away this week after  a long battle with cancer the family  asks for privacy at his time earlier  this month  Harry's mom shared this photo of her and  Robin celebrating their four year  anniversary  Harry talked about his mom and stepdad  support of his new album with BBC  earlier this year have you played it to  your mom I have and what did your mom  think my mom liked it yeah which was  handy yeah I played the album to the to  the success first time and there's one  song on the album where is like a bit  with like a vocal effect on it and my  stepdad goes where did you get the duck  from but how did you get definiteness to  that I'm like yeah that was me Thanks  [Music]  you